[Music]
were you into movies do you know much
about movies i was i was very much into
movies like you know i wasn't the most
social kid i was kind of a heavier child
and so i would i was
one of those kids would just go hang i
don't know one of those kids i was a kid
who went to the video store and would
just read
the vhs boxes
and just memorize facts and particularly
the dates for when the movies would come
out i would memorize the date it was
released and it's still i still have all
that information logged
what in my brain so it's like a talent
it's not a talent sorry
it's something i can do
like if you throw a movie title at me i
can usually name the
the release date the year do you mind if
i try because i heard you had the skill
sure i mean most of the time not all of
the time goonies
uh that would be that would be 1984.
85 god damn it
the first one out of the box
[Laughter]
pretty woman
that would be 1990 yes
[Music]
thank you if you cheer i'm gonna get
really sad
this is the first time this has come
anywhere close to being an appliable
skill yeah
operation dumbo drop
that would be 199
four five god damn it
the breakfast club uh that would be
that would be 1984. 85.
pooty tang
my favorite movie title of all time
that would be
1999 2001. now listen
you spent your entire youth
studying
these boxes
listen
i got one right
[Applause]
it's just an enormous waste of time
you're like an underachieving rain man i
know
i couldn't be more proud of myself
how many matches on the floor rain man i
don't know
17. what
i don't care let's just say 40.
40-ish yeah i do love too that you were
saying at the beginning i was one of
those kids yeah you know when i'm
going to read video boxes there's no
other kid no
there's there's one watching right now
somewhere else yes yes finally another
like me
i will say to that kid if he exists the
only thing it will ever get you is
making you seem like a know-it-all
[ __ ]
that's it
because you're like hey i got this down
right yeah and then you go on television
and you don't know what you're talking